Guidel, c’est un formidable moment
d'échanges et de débats
sur l'ensemble des sujets
qui nous importe.
Qu'il s'agisse de l'actualité
nationale, européenne ou mondiale
et des perspectives que nous souhaitons
dresser pour notre pays.
Un journaliste politique
me disait : “Au MoDem,
vous êtes ceux qui réfléchissent le plus
avec l'ensemble de vos parties prenantes”,
de François Bayrou à nos ministres,
nos parlementaires, nos cadres, élus locaux
et évidemment l'ensemble
des adhérents du Mouvement Démocrate.
Et puis Guidel, bien évidemment,
c'est aussi des moments de convivialité
autour du fameux pot des régions,
mais également autour de nos villages
et aussi autour des questions de sport, de culture.
Et puis, avec quelques nouveautés
que vous aurez l'occasion
de découvrir à Guidel.
Et puis Guidel, c'est la famille,
c’est la réunion de la famille
sous le soleil de la Bretagne.
Guidel, c'est le 29, 30 septembre et 1ᵉʳ octobre.
Inscrivez-vous vite sur
ur.mouvementdemocrate.fr
et j'ai hâte de vous y retrouver.